just finished yesterday filming along 10
part series called mr. Selfridge which
is going to be on ITV hopefully I think
that beginning next year and it's about
the the man Harry said she started and
built Salford it and built it to stories
today so Jeremy Piven thing that lead
isn't it during Pitman plays the man who
says so it's been fantastic working with
him he's got all the charisma that you
would need to be a man who built the
store like services he was fantastic and
what can he expect from you in that film
I play a brilliantly named character
called Ellen love who is a showgirl and
she becomes Harry Selfridges mistress
and then the face of Selfridges and then
all sorts of other things happen and
what you got to think of those kind of
period dramas cuz it's very much in the
sort of line of Downton Abbey and those
sort of things that Titanic isn't it
yeah I think I think that people have a
hunger for that and I think we do them
so well in this country so it's it's
fantastic to be part of and I think this
particular drama is really gonna blow
everyone stocks of these ultra glamorous
ultra brilliant and yeah I loved being a
part of it
you